today on the matt walsh show a recent
survey shows just how thoroughly the
media has misled the public on the topic
of police shootings also five headlines
including dr fauci stating that society
will not be allowed to go back to normal
until he says so he's the boss and
biden's health secretary pick
tries to dodge questions about his
support for infanticide
in our daily cancellation we'll cancel
the chief of cherokee nation who demands
that jeep stop using his tribe's name
though he can't explain why
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
in recent years the media has been in a
much
publicized war against misinformation
one might think it would be quite easy
for them to slay that particular dragon
all they have to do is
stop misinforming people they are after
all the primary purveyors
of fake news in all of its forms some
people may be
led astray by you know facebook memes
and random tweets that
pop into their twitter feeds but the
internet trolls who spread lies in
innuendo through those avenues are mere
amateurs compared to the american media
the latter group has
elevated misinformation to an art form
they have perfected it
they are experts in the field and now
the world's greatest misinformers
have been have given themselves the task
of combating
misinformation it's a classic case of
the fox guarding the hen house
but if misinformation is the media's art
form then their narrative
around police shootings is their mona
lisa their pieta their their masterpiece
on no other issue is the general public
so thoroughly
dis deluded misled and confused and on
no other issue has the consequence of
that delusion
been so utterly catastrophic billions of
dollars of damage inflicted
hundreds of buildings torched dozens of
people murdered disastrous
public policies and laws enacted and
this just over the past nine months
thanks almost exclusively to the media's
misinformation campaign
about police shootings a recent survey
from skeptic magazine illustrates
in profound terms exactly how effective
this campaign has been
interviewing a sample of american adults
across the political spectrum
researchers asked the people two
questions
one if you had to guess how many unarmed
black men were killed by police in 2019
and respondents were given options that
ranged from about ten
to over ten thousand two if you had to
guess
in 2019 what percentage of people killed
by police were black
and here the survey group could respond
with any percentage between
zero and 100. the responses to these two
questions
reveal confusion intentionally
cultivated confusion on a massive
scale thirty percent of those
identifying as very liberal
guessed that about 100 unarmed black men
had been killed by police in 2019.
38 percent of self-identified liberals
um
guessed the same so they got very
liberal and liberal
as did 40 of moderates 40 of
conservatives and 33 percent of
very conservatives 31 of the very
liberal group
thought that the number of unarmed black
men killed by police was around a
thousand
as did 26 of liberals 16
of moderates 9 of conservatives and 13
percent of varied conservatives
there were even sizable portions of each
group that thought that 10
000 or more unarmed black men had been
fatally shot by police in a single
calendar year
for very liberals it was over 20 that
thought that
liberals 11 moderates 8 conservatives 4
very conservative 6 percent now the
actual number
of unarmed black men killed by police in
2019 according to the washington post
database is
thirteen thirteen
not a hundred not a thousand not ten
thousand thirteen
and even thirteen is likely a
significant overestimation as i
previously showed
only six of the 13 unarmed shootings in
that year was were clearly unjustified
only one was a case of apparent murder
and that officer has been charged
accordingly you could make a case for
manslaughter in two or three of the
other cases
and those officers have been charged
with crimes too but in eight of the 13
unarmed shootings the suspects were in
the process of
running officers down in their cars
violently assaulting them or otherwise
presenting themselves as lethal threats
for example kevin mason of baltimore's
categorized as an unarmed man shot by
cops and he was
but he also told officers that he had a
gun and intended to quote kill every
last one of them
marzu scott was shot while unarmed but
only because he assaulted a female
officer
knocked her to the ground and forced her
to use the gun after her taser was
ineffective
isaiah lewis pounced on an officer and
knocked him unconscious before getting
shot he also may have been unarmed but
he was no less of a threat because of it
the point is that not every unarmed
shooting is unjustified or even really
unarmed
in fact at least in 2019 most of the
unarmed shooting
shootings were clearly justified
putting all that to the side we're left
with quote about 10
unarmed black men and one woman shot by
cops in 2019.
what this means is that the majority of
people in
every ideological category overestimated
the number by
at least a factor of ten huge numbers of
liberals and moderates over
overestimated by factors of a hundred or
a thousand
the situation isn't much better for the
second question
on average liberals thought that between
55 and 60
of people killed by police in 2019 were
black moderates thought the figure was
around 45
conservatives and very conservatives
thought it was between 35 and 45
again all of the groups missed the mark
by a wide margin in reality only 23.4
percent of those killed by police in
2019 were black
between 2015 and 2020 the figure
averages out to about 26 percent
conservatives came the closest to the
truth but even they tacked on an
imaginary 20 percent
on top of the 23 that it actually was
now you might argue that the average
person isn't spending much time
researching the exact demographic
details of police shootings in 2019 or
any other year
okay this is part of my job so i've done
the research i've looked into it
um not everybody has and so you might
say well it's not not very surprising
that they get it wrong in a survey of
this sort but the problem
isn't that they didn't know the precise
number
it's that they couldn't land in the
ballpark or even in the neighborhood of
the ballpark
the average person may not know exactly
the number of americans killed each year
by lightning strikes but
if i gave you options of you know here's
a survey question how many americans are
killed each year by lightning strikes
your options are around 50 around 5000
or around
50 000. now i'm guessing that you
already
thought to yourself well it's probably
around 50. and that's correct
that's because the average person has
the capacity to make reasonable
judgments about the threat posed by
lightning strikes we all know they
happen but we also know they're pretty
rare and
there's no way in hell that lightning
bolts from the sky are smiting
50 000 people in this country every year
the idea that police are killing 1 000
or 10 000 unarmed black people
in a year or that half of the people
killed each year by police are black is
just as absurd it's just as obviously
bogus but the average person can't see
the absurdity for what it is because
their judgment and capacity for making
reasonable estimations on this issue has
been obliterated after years of
relentless propaganda from the media
this is what we're up against for all of
the skepticism rightly targeted at the
media
even the skeptics can be wildly misled
by that same media
no matter how much of an independent
thinker a critical thinker
you might consider yourself to be it's
difficult
to keep your wits about you when
surrounded by a constant fog
of lies and half truths ed harris's
character in the truman show
had it right when he said we accept the
reality of the world with which we're
presented
it's as simple as that and it is indeed
that simple for many of us
but it shouldn't be as we have learned
time and time again
the reality and what we are presented
can often be two very different things
let's get now to five headlines
so we've heard from fauci in sort of
vague terms in recent days implying
that the masking and social distancing
and all of that would have to continue
even for people
who are vaccinated uh basically
indefinitely
but now we have him in a teleconference
uh i think with the national institute
of health
being being as clear and explicit on
this subject as we've heard him
so far and here's what he had to say
listen
there are certain aspects of being
vaccinated and what that means to you
personally and your own personal safety
and that of your family
versus what vaccines will allow you to
do in society
one relates to you yourself being
vaccinated
and the other relates to the number of
people and the relative percentage of
people in society
that will be vaccinated because there
will be things
that you will not be able to do because
the burden of virus in society
will be very high which it is right now
even though we're going way down
on the decline that dr walensky showed
you
we are still at an unacceptably high
baseline
level with the seven day average being
quite high so there are things even if
you're vaccinated
that you're not going to be able to do
in society for example
indoor dining theaters places where
people congregate
that's because of the safety of society
you yourself
what you can do when you are together
with another
person we are looking at that and we're
going to try and find out very quickly
what recommendations could be made about
what people can do
okay so there we go um they're they're
looking at it you know what what can you
do with another person
if you're waiting around uh for a guy
like fauci to tell you what you can do
when you're around another person
then he's looking at it and uh he'll get
back to you that but for right now
sit on your couch with your hands tucked
under
under your legs and and don't move and
don't touch anything and don't talk to
anybody and he'll get back to you let
you know exactly what you're allowed to
do
in your own house with uh with with
other people
i mean if if you are actually still
waiting around for guys like fauci to
give you the okay before you go and live
your life then
um then i don't know what to tell you i
don't know there's nothing i could do
for you really i mean
you're a hopeless case at this point uh
you are you are
hopelessly mindless if you're still
waiting for a guy like fouchy to give
you the okay
of course unfortunately they're
depending on where you live there may be
a lot of things that you want to do that
you actually can't do because they've
been shut down
now i will say i part of me laughs when
i hear stuff like this like um
well you know it's we'll find out
soon enough when we can start doing
things like indoor dining again
i've been doing indoor dining since the
spring
i took a brief pause in indoor dining
because i had to because where i live
they shut down all the restaurants
but they opened up after about a month
and i'm going out with my wife
regularly uh to to go eat
and you know it's it and if if
restaurants are open around you and
again but you you would rather
sit around and and still order doordash
or whatever and pay the
the extra 45 fee they tack on top of it
for soggy cold food if you want to do
that then fine i mean it's more room for
the rest of us i guess at the restaurant
but you shouldn't be waiting around
anymore
you have you just have to think about it
i always have to emphasize this
because it's it's important for us to
stay under for us to understand
psychologically
um guys like fauci you know this is not
like some kind of conspiracy theory
this is a basic understanding of human
nature
fauci over the last year
has been given enormous power
over our everyday lives now in reality
in actuality he should have no power
over what any of us do
he's not an elected official he's not
he's not a lawmaker
he's not a law enforcement officer he
should really have no power over us but
he's been given
enormous power and also prominence and
fame
how many people knew fauci's name before
before all this started now he's a
household name
household name incredibly famous still
loved and adored uh by somehow by many
people
and with with incredible power it it's
even for for people of great
virtue and humility and integrity
which i don't think any of that applies
to fouchy but even if you had all that
stuff
and then you're given that kind of power
and that kind of fame
and that kind of recognition and a claim
and all that it is very difficult to not
be
corrupted by it number one and also very
difficult to
willingly give it up
because the minute that fauci says okay
you know what we could start
moving back to normal this uh the virus
is is really receding
we've gotten a hold of it now you know
millions of people have already been
infected they're immune to it millions
more are getting vaccinated and so you
can go and live your
your daily life and you'll probably be
fine the minute that factory says that
then
he goes back to basic irrelevance nobody
cares he's not doing the he's
no one's calling him in for interviews
anymore he's not he's not giving uh
press conferences that 50 million people
are going to watch
he goes back to having no you're just
being a basically a nameless bureaucrat
i don't think he wants to give that up
and it's not just him
there are a lot of people from fouchy's
level all the way down to your
local bureaucrats you know town halls
school boards all that kind of stuff
they have been given importance and
power and prestige that they've never
had before
and they don't want to give it up so
always keep that in mind when you hear
these people
speaking number two on monday virginia's
state senate passed a bill it was
already approved by the house of
delegates officially banning this is
from the daily wire officially banning
the death penalty in the southern state
the bill now awaits to be signed into
law by democratic governor ralph northam
which is expected the bill would join
virginia with 22 other states that have
voted to end capital punishment
the associated press reported that
virginia has executed more people in its
long history than any other so now
virginia
under ralph northam uh is gearing up to
ban the death penalty it's a pretty
major story pretty major development
and what that's going to mean is that in
virginia under ralph northam
uh and we should remember this when we
hear well the death penalty is
is abolished in virginia not exactly
it there's a qualifier needed here the
death penalty is abolished in virginia
for adults what this means is that as an
adult
you can no longer receive the death
penalty no matter what you do
you could go out rape and kill kill
children and
there's in virginia like in like in 22
other states now
there's nothing that you can do that
will earn you death
no matter how heinous um
i mean no matter how much you send the
message to society that you don't want
to be a part of it
that you don't want to be treated like a
human being because you want to act like
an animal no matter how much you do it
society is still going to keep you
around and keep you alive and pay money
too to keep you around and keep you
alive
it not just that but but in fact
the more heinous your crime the more
money society has to pay
to house you and keep you alive in
prison
because you're gonna need protect if you
if you do something so horrible
let's say you you rape and murder a
child
it's so horrible that even the other
murderers in prison hate you for it
well now you need protective custody for
your whole life that's going to cost
even more money
so society has to society has to assume
the burden
the extra burden to pay more money to
keep you alive
because what you did was so heinous
so that's the situation in virginia for
adults
but children can still be executed in
virginia like in all the other states
children can still receive the death
penalty and due to the tune of about a
million a year
ralph northam famously infamously
is in favor of the death penalty for
infants born infants
the child is born we can make a decision
about what to do with the child
can't do that with a child murderer we
can't make any decisions there there's
no decision to be made
keep them alive three hot meals a day
for their whole life
uh sort of on the same subject here
number three biden has nominated xavier
becerra to be the new health secretary
he has no medical background of any kind
as far as i can tell but he's going to
be health secretary
for whatever reason the greater concern
is that he's a he's an infanticidal
lunatic
um like every other democrat like ralph
northam like the whole democratic party
senator romney questioned him yesterday
in hearing about that about his support
of infanticide
partial birth abortion specifically and
let's listen to that exchange
there's a division in our country with
regards to the issue of abortion of
course as you know
and mainstream republicans mainstream
republicans democrats disagree
but most people agree that partial birth
abortion uh
is awful you voted against a ban on
partial birth abortion
why so senator here um
i understand that people have different
deeply held beliefs
on this issue and i respect that
i have worked as i've mentioned for
decades
trying to protect the health of men and
women young and old
and as attorney general my job has been
to follow the law and make sure others
are following the law
and i'm also sitting in front of a high
risk ob gyn
who for several decades had the work of
protecting the health of women
and a future baby and so i will tell you
that when
i come to these issues i understand that
we may not always agree
on where to go but i think we can find
some common ground
on these issues because everyone wants
to make sure that
if you have an opportunity you're going
to live a healthy life and i will tell
you that i
i hope to be able to work with you and
others to reach that common ground on so
many different issues
i think we can reach common ground on
many issues but on partial birth
abortion
it sounds like we we're not going to
reach uh common ground there
yeah i don't agree with romney there
there's no common ground and uh yeah he
he says i respect i respect everyone's
opinion he didn't answer the question at
all if you noticed
he the question was very simple it
wasn't a gotcha question
wasn't trapping him at all he just said
romney asked
you voted against a ban on partial birth
abortion
why the simplest question you voted
why'd you do that
uh and didn't didn't get an answer no
answer instead it's all i respect i
deeply respect the
deeply held views of everyone and i
deeply respect all the deeply
all the deep things that are happening
in this deep country um well it's nice
that you respect everyone's view i don't
really believe you that you respect
everyone's views
but i'll be honest with you and tell you
that i don't respect your views at all
um i also don't respect you as a person
as a man at all i don't respect you
because if you get this issue wrong then
you're not deserving of any respect at
all as a human being
okay you are a disgrace and a scumbag
that's what you are
you're you are you are a terrible excuse
for a man
and for an american so i have no i want
to be really clear about that
you get this issue wrong i have
absolutely no respect for your opinion
which is horrific and stupid and i have
no respect for you
as a horrifically stupid person partial
birth abortion
is we talked yesterday about the
males in the females sports leagues and
how that's the easiest societal question
we faced
despite the fact that another one of
biden's nominees was saying how
difficult it is so it's such a difficult
question all these questions they find
so difficult
well i might have to amend my statement
i said that's i said the the female
sport thing is the ease is actually
is in fact the easiest societal question
we've ever faced um
i'll amend that and say actually partial
birth abortion or really abortion
generally especially parthal burst
abortion is the easiest
question in partial birth abortion
you're you're taking a child who is in
the process of being born this is a
fully developed child an infant
okay you can't hide behind embryo here
it's not an
embryo this is a fully developed infant
you take any any
any newborn child you've seen and
lovingly cradled
in its mother's arms that's what the
child looks like in the partial birth
abortion
in the process of being born and you are
murdering that child
as it emerges from the birth canal and
you're doing it in the birth canal on a
technicality
because you know that once once once the
child emerges from the birth canal
uh now it will legally count as
infanticide unless guys like ralph
northam get their way in which case even
then you could kill
which really by the logic of late term
abortion you may as well
kill children who are five days old or
five months old or five years old
because morally there's no difference
and you can't hide behind any excuses
about it's a woman's body a woman can
the baby is in the process of leaving
the woman's body
so even even if i bought into your
bodily autonomy
arguments for abortion which i don't but
even if i did
that's out the window the child's in the
process of being born he's not gonna be
in your body anymore
the question is are you going to kill
that child a second before it's born
are you going to take the extra step of
killing that child before it's born
if you do and if you are in favor of
that you're simply in favor of murder
that's it
you are in favor of murdering a baby
because it's an inconvenience to
society to the mother whatever
and yeah so i mean call me crazy
but if you if you think it's it there is
ever a scenario where it could be okay
to suck the brains out of a baby
then i don't respect you or your opinion
and i think you know that your opinion
is
not worthy of respect which is why you
won't defend it
you can't defend it and you know it
all right let's go uh number four here
you heard a lot about the
kids in cages during trump's term that
was
obviously a ridiculous false narrative
talking about false narratives
police shootings i think that's number
one
on the list of false narratives from the
media but kids in cages
the only reason that isn't number one is
because the consequences of that lie
have not been nearly as dire as the
consequences of the police shooting lie
that's a simple lie
and one of the reasons that you knew it
was a lie from the beginning when the
left was going on about kids in cages
and how worried they are about it and
and all of that one of the reasons you
knew it was a lie
it goes back to what we were just
discussed that there's no way
these people actually give a damn anyway
any that's uh that's a a hint for
everybody
anytime someone on the left is
pretending to care about children
you know something is up because they
don't actually care
there's got there's something else going
on here something is wrong
anytime someone on the left is
pretending to care about children
and probably what they're saying is
completely bogus as it was here so
uh the kids and cage narrative was was
bogus um
and but it was pushed by the media and
democrats and biden himself interesting
thing now though is that biden
himself is keeping migrant kids in the
same places that trump was keeping them
jen saki was asked about this at a press
conference
and here's how that went and to ensure
the health and safety of these kids
hhs took steps to open an emergency
facility to add capacity
where these children can be provided the
care they need while they are safely
before they are safely placed with
families
and sponsors so it's a temporary
reopening during covet 19.
our intention is very much to close it
but we want to ensure that we can follow
covet protocols uh as we uh as we as
unaccompanied minors come into the
united states but it's the same facility
that was
open for a month in the trump
administration summer 2019
that is when joe biden said under trump
there have been horrifying scenes at the
border of kids being kept in cages and
kamala harris said
uh basically babies and cages is a human
rights
abuse being committed by the united
states government so how is this any
different than that we very much feel
that way
uh and these are facilities let me be
clear here
one there's a pandemic going on i'm sure
you're not suggesting that we have
children right next to each other uh in
ways that are not coveted safe are you
i'm suggesting that kamala harris said
that
this facility putting people in this
facility was a human rights abuse
committed by the united states
government and jill biden said
under trump there have been horrifying
scenes of border
uh at the border of kids being kept in
cages now it's not under trump it's
under by me
this is not kids being kept in cages
this is this
is kids this is a facility that was
opened
that's going to follow the same
standards as other hhs facilities it is
not a replication
certainly not though that's that is
never our intention of replicating the
immigration policies of the past
administration oh okay
all right well well fine then never mind
they're not cages they're facilities now
you see there's a clear difference it's
exactly the same
situation the exact same place
everything's the same
but uh not cages they're facilities
that's all yeah well they were
facilities all along
and yes that's see that's that's the
point um
and that's why this the tricky thing you
run into anytime you're trying to hold
democrats to their own standard
or to the standards that they've applied
to you
because we can we can criticize biden
for this
immigration policy because he criticized
trump for the same
and mischaracterized and lied about it
but we're not saying that what's
happening right now is wrong like of
course
the kids are here especially if they're
unaccompanied you know
what else are you going to do just send
them off into the wild world by
themselves
you have to when when people are coming
here
and especially if they're coming here
illegally you got to do
something and if we're talking about
kids you have to have a place
for them and we also know to complicate
matters that
um that oftentimes the adults
with the children may pose as parents
but oftentimes are not actually the
parents this could be a trafficking
situation you don't know
you don't know you have no way of
knowing
this is the situation that you know
the the the law enforcement officials
immigration officials are put in
because of the decision to you know
among illegal
immigrants to do that to commit that
crime
and to involve kids in it
so there's no perfect answer
there there's there's a lot of times
there's no happy conclusion you have to
do something
and it makes sense to have yes
facilities
so we're not criticizing that however we
also can't
let you get away with this without
pointing out what you're doing
so that's the that's the balancing act
that we always find ourselves in when
dealing with the hypocrisy of the left
number five finally i thought this was
fantastic some cops in pakistan have
adopted
a new crime fighting strategy which is
rollerblading
we have the video here let's play some
of this video of the rollerblading
cops and there's some cool there's like
some cool 80s
music that goes with it just just just
perfect music for this
almost perfect music i think what we
really need is maybe
is maybe something something 90s maybe
ace of base
even limp biscuit and uh but they're
rollerblading
one cop pulls his gun out while they're
while they're rollerblading
what i want to see now is what i want to
see now is a gang of criminals
on skateboards so we can have a
rollerblade versus skateboard battle
that's what i actually want to see
it's become like a movie or something
there's the music
a movie that i might have written in
fourth grade the other thing that's
missing here with these rollerblading
cops is um
walk walk mans i'm not sure if the
plural is supposed to be walkman or
walkmans i was never sure but uh you
know the walkman cassette player that i
had
when i was in fourth grade maybe fanny
packs
i don't know but this is great
i don't know how do you take a cop
seriously
i have enough trouble taking the cops
seriously on bikes i understand the bike
cop thing i mean it's a practical
solution
especially in the city um it's hard
though to take someone seriously as a
you know as a
as a figure of authority when they're on
a bike with a bike helmet
and in rollerblades it makes it even
worse but
i appreciate it creative you know
ingenuity is what we need in law
enforcement so that's great
all right let's move on now to reading
the youtube comments here are some
comments from the show yesterday
from username history and headlines he
says
it's pretty clear that what happened
over the summer was domestic terrorism
yeah pretty clear to you and i
to the guy that's going to be the
attorney general though um merrick
garland
not very clear at all because as we
learned yesterday and he and he actually
said this this is not me he's not
hyperbole i'm not exaggerating
not a straw man he actually said that
domestic terrorism at night doesn't
count it might still be a crime but it's
not domestic terrorism because you do it
at night
um jenny v says
came for shapiro but now it's all about
mats when will we see you do more shows
or longer shows
well i'm i do five shows a week we put
out content on saturdays too
i am doing longer shows like the shows
are 45 minutes to 50 minutes at this
point what more do you want from me
jenny what more do you want from me what
else can i do for you
back off but thanks for watching
uh floor saza says matt you're pretty
damn sexy with big guns and a fantastic
beard
oh you're also a great chef chef you
know i don't like being cat-called and
there's far too much of that happening
in the comments i've noticed
actually i do like being cat-called
let's be honest about it
getting cat called is great i don't know
why women complain about it
it's it what's what's the problem people
are saying complimenting you
i don't have an issue with it you can
compliment me all you want
um let's see nicholas says okay let's
get some more serious topics
when is your easter candy review well i
don't have much of a review for easter
candy i'm in favor of giving people
freedom to
eat whatever candy they want on easter
unless it's peeps
or the big jelly beans so only the small
gourmet jelly beans are acceptable
um they're the only ones worth a damn
big jelly beans can go to hell peeps can
go to hell
and if you eat those things you can too
that was a little strong
i'll back up a little bit i won't i
won't wish eternal damnation on you for
eating the bigger jelly beans but
seriously
get better taste and finally wayne says
hey matt love the show i've been
listening to it since march of last year
i'm from namibia
and here there's a lot of trophy hunting
yes you're right the meat
does go to the local locals in the area
there are small shops that clean up the
skins horns and heads of these animals
and they get money as a result it shows
that people in the west know nothing
about trophy hunting and it's
um and its benefits to the local
community here
firstly all hunts are documented and
highly regulated by the government it's
like people think that
others just come here and shoot animals
that were in a park or something
no there's immense regulation it's quite
expensive and each head of something
like a giraffe can be up to a hundred
thousand dollars
these shootings usually happen in
conservation farms owned by commercial
farmers and this is one of the driving
forces of tourism
and conservation in my country
specifically well
even though i don't know a lot about
trophy hunting i said yesterday that i
suspect it's probably okay because of
the way that it benefits the people
in that region and based on your
knowledge
uh in namibia wayne i will say that uh
yeah i'm i i
i will officially declare that i am
firmly in the
camp of pro-trophy i am totally in favor
of
if it benefits people you know if we're
using
animals in a way uh where we're not
being like
reckless and destructive for its own
sake but we're using them in a way that
benefits people
and people who need that benefit you
know people who need the food especially
need the money
so we think about the people that depend
on the food and the money from the
tourism for for
trophy hunting if we were to take that
away
because westerners it makes their
tummies hurt when they see pictures of
giraffes
laying dead um
you know we take that away and it it it
harms people so i'm not in favor of that
kill all the giraffes you want but you
know do it in the way that benefits
people
and uh it's not it i'm not gonna fly
two thousand three thousand miles away
or more to go um
kill a giraffe but uh if you wanna do it
in this way then
more power to you godspeed and god bless
you know there's a silver lining to a
lot of
things that may seem bad at first but
when it comes to acne i would say
there's no real
silver lining it's just a bad thing that
nobody wants there are no benefits to it
and that's why if you have acne you want
to find a solution
and that's why you need proactive
proactive combines gentle skin care
paired with the best acne treatment for
your skin
proactive has three different systems
designed for your skin type no matter
your type of breakout proactive combines
gentle skin care
and they're gonna and they're gonna find
a solution for you so the three systems
go this way number one they have
proactive md advanced
this is the prescription strength stuff
for stubborn breakouts
then they have proactive plus gentle for
more gentle
sensitive skin types if you need
something that's really specified to
your skin
type then proactive gentle is the way to
go then there's also proactive solution
original and this is the original system
suitable for all skin types and that's
kind of whatever the situation you know
you can't go wrong
with that with clinically proven
ingredients and tested by dermatologists
they've got the simple three-step system
designed for you and
what that means is that when you get
proactive you are subscribing to
consistently clear skin
this is a problem that if you have you
don't have to live with you don't have
to deal with every day
you just got to get proactive and be
proactive and dealing with the problem
right now is a great time to try
proactive for our podcast listeners you
can get a special offer
available by going to proactive.com
walsh proactive subscribers will receive
the hydrating duo as a free gift that
includes four
hydrogel masks and the green tea
moisturizer you also get free shipping
on top of it
again visit proactive.com waltz to take
advantage of this special offer now
that's proactive.com walsh and subscribe
to clearskin
also i want to tell you that tonight
february 24th is this month's backstage
you don't want to miss it because look
we entered 2021 with our debut in the
world of entertainment
and we've been keeping the big news
coming ever since then we announced the
big movie deal with gina carano there's
a lot going on we're going to talk about
all of that today
if you're not already a daily wire
member you can go to dailywire.com
subscribe and join us before backstage
so that you can ask questions that we
will then answer on the air
we'll also be talking about ben
shapiro's new series debunked
there are so many narratives about hot
topic issues we talked about
one of them today with the police
shootings so many others climate change
universal healthcare covered policies
all of that stuff
and what ben is going to do is he's
going to expose the leftist fallacies on
all these different topics
using facts and logic ben's new show
will be available exclusively to daily
wire members so if you aren't already a
member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked for 25
off
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we are canceling the chief of
the cherokee nation chuck hoskin jr
it appears that chuck has decided that
it's time for
a jeep to stop using the cherokee name
on its jeep cherokees
which have been on the market under that
label for something like 40 years chuck
is concerned
that jeep has appropriated the cherokee
name now i'm tempted to say that if jeep
has to give back
that name cherokee then i think chuck
has to give the name
chuck back toss white people
but i'm not going to say that i'm
tempted to say it but i'm not saying
instead let's just listen to the
cherokee chief himself
explain his reasoning such as it is here
it is listen
today in 2021 as chief of the cherry
connection i i am saying
categorically that i think it's wrong to
use our name
to peddle a vehicle for most people
uh tribes don't even maybe seem real uh
in terms of
uh their experience seeing something in
history and
naming something after something in
history probably doesn't feel too bad
particularly if it engenders some strong
positive emotions but i think in this
year 2021 we ought to be talking about
the fact that tribes are still here
we're vibrant we do a great deal for our
people and our communities and that our
names mean something
and they've been here a lot longer than
the jeep company and other
corporations that have seized our name
for profit
is there some way that you could use
that name that
you'd be fine with it well there's no
way that they could use the name that i
would be fine with it
it certainly doesn't honor us by using
that name and and
it was surely never intended to now just
to clarify here if you're listening to
the audio podcast
that was not ted cruz i know it sounds
exactly like it i mean
exactly like it it does but i don't want
you to have conjured in your head an
image of ted cruz
in a native american headdress
pretending to be a tribal chief
there's already one person in the u.s
senate pretending to be native american
we don't need another
so that was not ted cruz no that was in
fact chuck hoskin jr
and you heard his reasoning um it could
be summarized i think in three key
points
number one it's the year 2021
number two it's wrong to use the
cherokee name to peddle a vehicle
and number three the cherokee tribe
still exists so those are his three
reasons i think i think i'm fairly
summarizing them right
now i would respond to those points this
way
number one that's not an argument number
two that's not an argument either and
number three neither is that none of
those are arguments
the fact that it's the current year and
not some other year does not itself
explain why
any course of action is wrong or right
indeed it is
always the current year that's the crazy
thing it has never been anything but the
current year
there has never been a time when people
have lived in a year that was not the
current year
like yeah it's 2021 and people are
living in 2021 and not in you know 2007
but in 2007 they lived in 2007 and not
1982.
that's the way it works none of this
even begins to explain why jeep
shouldn't put the name
cherokee on some of its vehicles also
simply stating that it's wrong to use
the cherokee name to peddle a vehicle
doesn't explain why it's wrong that's
the assertion
that's the proposition you're trying to
defend you can't defend it by
saying it and restating it over and over
and again using slightly different words
this is something that people nowadays
don't seem to understand especially on
the internet
an assertion is not an argument
the argument is is is what you present
to defend
or explain the assertion it's not like
it's self-evident
it's not at all evident to me why it's
inherently wrong to use the name of a
tribe to sell a vehicle
it's just a name after all names are
fluid things they're used in different
ways they take on different meanings
you think that a culture that wants
everything to be fluid wants even
biological reality to be fluid
could understand that that names really
are fluid
gender is not fluid names actually are
that's one of the reasons why
if a man claims to be a woman and uh
and says my name is susan i'll call him
susan because a name
you could pick whatever name you want
now i'm not going to pretend that you're
a woman because you're not and you can't
pick whatever gender you want
so names are fluid and i'm sure if i go
back far enough i can find a time when
the cherokee
weren't even called the cherokee
what we're seeing here is this very
weird dynamic where in representation
is considered so important it's an
urgent necessity to make sure that
minority groups are portrayed named
mentioned
shown all the time everywhere but at the
same time
the very same people fighting for
representation also are fighting to
remove
representation you know it's a victory
for minority groups to be represented
it's also somehow a victory
that native american groups are less
represented in general culture today
than they were a year ago
so which is it are we supposed to be
representing or not
the only way to make sense of this
seeming contradiction is to see the
native american identity
and the names associated with it as
somehow specially sacred
and deserving of of reverence you know
there's there's there's nothing
insulting about the jeep cherokee
there was nothing insulting about the
native american woman that was used on
the uh
the lando lakes butter containers the
only way to see this stuff as
inappropriate is to ascribe an almost
mystical quality to the native american
identity
but it's not mystical or sacred or
deserving of any sort of
religious reverence native americans are
people we put all kinds of people
and names on cars sports teams helmets
uh
product packaging etc there's no reason
why native americans should be exempt
from that
so the only logical response then to
chuck in this case is to say
dude get over yourself just get over
yourself
but we all know that is not the response
that he's going to receive in fact jeep
in response to this totally manufactured
controversy said quote
our vehicle names have been carefully
chosen and nurtured over the years to
honor and celebrate native american
people for their nobility prowess and
pride
we are more than ever committed to a
respectful and open dialogue with the
cherokee nation principal chief chuck
hoskin jr uh-oh
the open dialogue we all know where this
is headed
i mean there should be no dialogue they
should say to chuck yeah we aren't going
to talk about that because it's stupid
that should be it that should be the
beginning and end of their statement
but they're open to a dialogue which
means that within six months we're going
to get the big announcement that jeep is
helping to end racism by erasing yet
another cultural reference to native
americans hooray
i am certain that this is where that
that is where this is gonna go
uh and for that reason i am canceling
jeep too preemptively
i won't even give them a chance they are
canceled
chuck is canceled ted cruz is canceled
in case that really was him
everyone is cancelled and that'll do it
for us today
thanks for listening thanks for watching
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledowski
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show a grand
jury declines to indict police officers
in the death of black man daniel prude
the first black bachelor complains about
systemic racism and democrats struggle
with joe biden putting kids in cages
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen